welcome to this video playing hypnotic
Specter from the u.s. let's see
one of the more frequent opponents oh I
have a great score against him five and
a half points out of six possible oops
Hey okay oh why not I wanted to wanted
to play a six but yeah let's play in a
wood Indian
I really have don't do that usually old
Indian with d65
just like the King's Indian but with the
bishop only seven of course this is
entirely different like it's not going
for any Kings side play like in the
Kings Indian very often get g6 f5 and
here it's some Queen side issue mostly
one idea that black tries to accomplish
is b5 and in the long run
interesting okay what I wanted to say is
b5 and an Knight to Bishop to b6 Bishop
d8 b6 one idea
now he has some reason has allowed the
structure which looks really comfortable
now I get the c5 square not quite sure
what the point is I thought maybe he
would play before a five Bishop e3 even
he didn't even do that he just gave me
the c5 square you know this is some
logical move maybe you will challenge
this night with night b3 so I'm moving
it the other one to d7 so that I've
replacement light on t7 and I'm also
preparing Bishop g5 to get them red
Bishop only seven exchanged you know
Bishop g5 blunders the d6 pawn so cannot
do that I could I could play Knight to
b6 get yeah come on let's do that this
is a very strong piece on c4 it always a
text e6 so I better better get it get it
off the board Knight e4 yeah that's a
threat
yeah okay I need to I need to remove the
coin it's not so great on v6 anyway yeah
that's a very very strategic approach
he's exchanging his potentially bad
bishop form my good one and tries to
prove that I have a bad Bishop on his
heaven this is why I'm playing c4 to
make sure this bishop is not a bad
Bishop it should have a good place on c5
potentially on deform so this is why I
played c4 okay so let's see you should I
take
maybe but first let's do that so that
Queen b6 coming Queen b6 actually
threatens to be five point and I want to
provoke a for him this would help me as
a for weekends before so that I can
always have an eye Bishop on before that
supports this pawn operation
my next move would be Queen b6
interesting maybe a3 is this idea but I
will still attack upon you so where'd
you go to d6 I'm briefly wondering what
if I just what if I just take b5 it's
got the D pawn this is some problem
hmm yeah come on it's still interesting
let's do that it's just the Blitz game I
have them have very strong pawns on c4
and before and tonight on b1 is not
really a good piece okay I'm
anticipating that he takes it but yeah
we need to take before cannot I cannot
really believe any other mousse is
playable yeah I think this is a mistake
to spend any time
whatever what other moves is there
besides taking okay
very conservative maybe maybe attacking
here yeah okay okay this just drop back
and be satisfied with this
accomplishment now the ideas Bishop d7
and b5 Bishop d7 yeah
Bishop Bishop he M
he's playing in a very as mentioned very
strategically um clean manner he some
preserved Sebastian yeah the passer
connected pass on okay I've got the
April just not so bad as well so taking
or not and let's get active
check again I am he needs to play place
the rock passively trying to get it with
the king let's see King here first
yeah let's place the rope here to cut
off the king yeah King F 2 white resigns
yeah very tough game very tough game
yeah I think he should have taken the
the piece I mean it was it wasn't clear
I think but I think the way he played he
also he also kept something some some
edge you know Queen takes a funny move I
don't really think it's working
but if I thought it was interesting I
mean it's just a blitz game yeah ok but
let's check this I'm a computer once a
chain with the Queen which is completely
ridiculous yeah but my place also
completely my idea is also completely
idiotic he can just play that news which
I forgot so that means I must take him
first Queen takes and then take here
Queenie - oopsie 892 and that's it yeah
it was just not working I mean just
I had completely forgot that my
attention after this was to take with
the pawn and I forgot about the
retreating moose which just picks up the
pawn I mean just for nothing so this
means this was very bad to take on b5
not playable at all
do I need to play him a normal move
Bishop back for example I'm still
threatening b5 so this is a playable
position yeah this is therefore not the
best he can just win worth taking it
yeah this should be M this should be
better for wine I mean it's a it's a
protected passer on d5 but he somehow
somehow screwed up I don't know yeah I
really have come to play it's probably
not for draw I mean we saw that f3 is
not not great at all I mean probably
still okay but not not great and I don't
really see a much better check I think
it with precise play you can probably
draw or let's say d6 yeah this is this
is note that this is not held so I need
to do something like this and it's a
dead position in the game yeah I can
still play more precisely King if to
this this is just giving it away go here
you can still keep the spawn attack I
don't think it can win and try to
approach here
now like it's the one going for it but
maybe I can't win I'm just threatening
to go all the way to be three hmm yeah
but he could have just taken the piece
so very lucky win thanks for watching